Another Thing That Doctor Bright Is Not Allowed
To Do At The Foundation: No interacting with
SCP-5555-J under any circumstances!
SCP-5555-J is capable of reducing any living
organism to a miniature (or chibi, if you’d
prefer) version of itself.
Dr. Bright may claim he is trying to make
teacup pigs to hand out at the office as an
incentive, but do not fall for it!
The last time Dr. Bright was exposed to SCP-5555-J,
the miniature version it produced of him was
a miniature orangutan.
He was brought into custody, and proceeded
to behave quite poorly with some of his own
bathroom material, and completely destroy
the attending researcher’s clothing, before
escaping to wreak even more havoc.
Dr. Bright knows what mini-him did, and he
has lost his 5555-J privileges for good.